どうも皆さんこんにちははじめんです
はいというわけで皆さんこのくそ暑い夏の日
どのようにお過ごしでしょうか？
こんだけ暑いともう逆に外に出る方が間違いなんじゃねってくらい
錯覚するくらい暑いんですけど
皆さん
どうされてますでしょうか？特に男子
女子は色々暑いと思うんですけど
何かこう肩とか出したりスカートとかでこう
すーすーすーできると思うんですけど
男はね
何かこう言う何か
タンクトップとかも着れると思うんですけど
僕にはそんな勇気がないので着れないです。
なんで基本的にTシャツとか長ズボンとか
半ズボンもね中々攻めっていうか着にくい方もいると思うんで
男の人は結構夏ね暑いと思うんですよ
勿論女性もですけど
そんな暑い中どのように熱をカバーしていくかといいますと
服の色とか素材だと思うんですよ
簡単な話からさせて頂きますと
黒い服っていうのは基本的に
遠赤外線効果で熱を吸収しやすいんで暑くなってしまいます
熱を吸収しながら暑くなっちゃう
なのでね本当は夏は黒い服ってあんまり夏よくないんですよ
外出る時。
で逆に白い服は遠赤外線効果が薄いので
熱の吸収が弱い
なので基本的に夏は皆さん白い服を着た方が
涼しいのかしれませんね。
だが
だが私は思った
私は思ってしまった
もっともっと涼しく夏を過ごす方法はないかと思った時に
昔理科の授業で習ったんですよ
黒い物は太陽の光を吸収して暑くなりやすい
白いのは太陽の光を何か弾いて何か大丈夫
で鏡金属みたいな鏡ってこう
光を当てると反射するじゃないですかこう
つまりですよ太陽の光も金属的なてかてかしたやつだったら
弾くんですよ光を反射して
黒みたいに吸収もしないし
光みたいに何かそんな何かうぇーってなんないし
多分金属メタルで服を作ったら
一番涼しいんじゃないかという事で
今回缶バッヂを何個だろう
準備しました
で多分かんないんですけど
こんだけの缶バッジを体中に着けて街を歩いたら
色という概念がない金属
え危なくね
怖っ
色という概念がないので全ての熱を遮断し
太陽光を弾くという感じで
全ての太陽光を弾いた時
多分涼しいんですよ
体中に缶バッジをつけて全ての太陽光を遮断し反射で弾き
一切体に熱を吸収しない状態を作り上げた方が
一番涼しく夏乗り切れるんじゃないかと私は思ったわけなので
早速この缶バッジ2400個を使って
全身金属の服を作って暑い外を歩いていこうと思います
では行こう
じゃあつけていきます
(ため息)
はいというわけでお待たせしました
全身缶バッジになってしまいました
あのまあパッと感じた感じ
凄い重いです体が
多分何かアベンジャーズみたいでちょっと
かっこいいです
やばいめっちゃじゃらじゃらいうんだけど
大事なのはここからです
これで外に行って太陽の光を浴び
果たして熱いのか暑くないか
そこが大事なポイントなので早速外に行ってみようと思います
行ってきます
おおっ
暑くない暑くないぞ暑くないぞ
暑くないかもしんない
カメラマン：まあそうなっちゃいますよ
何で？俺は暑さ対策してるだけなのに
マジでやばいんだって注目度が
皆俺を見るもん
そんな変かなぁ
歩いてみた感触暑くないっす思ったより
太陽的な暑さは本当に感じないっすカメラマン：流石
何か熱は遮断してますカメラマン：えーでもめっちゃ反射してるよ
カメラマン：マジめっちゃ反射してる
カメラマン：カメラ見るとやばいって多分
カメラマン：めっちゃ反射してる
はじめ：かっこいい
いやぁ悪目立ちするなぁこれ
涼しいんすよ太陽反射するんで
俺が今理論上一番涼しい
通行人：又お洒落になってるなと思って
はじめ：おしゃれ
通行人：最先端行ってるなぁと思って
はじめ：皆も真似してくれ
はじめ：暑いから気を付けてね
カメラマン：なるほどなるほど
カメラマン：マジはじめ：うん
カメラマン：あれ大丈夫っすかどうしたんすか
カメラマン：お疲れっすはじめ：お疲れっす
キンキンに冷えてる～
二度と着ません外して